a ver mucha importancia porque solo
hecho que se imponga la variedad de
género tanto para pueblos originarios
como para y los representantes de todos
los movimientos partidos e incluso
independientes
vas a hacer un uso un salto cuántico las
gracias tienen que antes nunca se había
hecho y me parece que es un tema también
que a nivel internacional ha llamado
mucho la atención el 50 por ciento de la
convención constituyente es decir 69
mujeres van a estar presentes ahí
cooperando redactar la constitución y
eso es un elemento de incorporación que
se debe tanto a los movimientos
feministas como a la labor a la propia
evolución de la sociedad en términos de
aceptación de la mujer en las
actividades tanto empresariales como
estatales y políticas y es hoy día está
claramente establecido y eso va a ser un
aporte sin lugar a duda y ese aporte que
probablemente va a permitir no solamente
colocar temas que de otra forma no
estarían presentes sino que también
llegará a acuerdos y acuerdos que sean
mucho más sustantivos en términos de que
son representativos de todo el cuerpo
social donde no solamente hay hombres o
mujeres sino que hay una
de personas con distintas creencias o
distintas tendencias deben estar también
representadas allí yo creo que el
sentido común femenino y el sentido
común que está exigiendo hoy día la
sociedad chilena va a estar bien
representado tanto por las mujeres y
también muy bien representados por los
hombres quienes va a tener que
definitivamente dejar y se quiere ver de
esa perspectiva no en el alineamiento
tradicionales patriarcales para poder
sentarse en una mesa de igual a igual a
discutir un futuro estilo